because when it comes to instances of
mass tragedies and the perpetrator's
left wing they disappear whenever the
bad guy whenever the person committing
the crime happens to fall into the
alignment of the corporate narrative
it's like uhoh can't have that one
getting out and the story vanishes well
it's like Jacksonville versus Nashville
just going to say that yeah the the
manifestos yeah that's right or how
about uh the guy who rammed the
Christmas parade in uh uh where was it w
and then it was just like no idea a
truck did it a truck crashed into these
people in the literal same city where
the Kyle Written House shootings happen
that was
Kos so but but I think they were
triggered by the it was a couple days
after uh CU we were in Austin at the
time and we W house had just gotten I
think within 48 hours this happened
right next to each other he posted uh uh
the guy had had some like BLM related
stuff on his Facebook page